[Music]
there has been a dramatic new
development in a case in california that
made international headlines years ago a
woman who admits that she faked her own
kidnapping agreed yesterday to plead
guilty to charges of lying to federal
officers and mail fraud
sherry papini faces potential prison
time and more than 300 thousand dollars
in restitution she has yet to be
sentenced papini you may recall
originally told investigators that two
hispanic women abducted and tortured her
for three weeks lilia luciano traveled
to reading california to find out how
her lies affected residents in that
small attack that small latino community
there
34 year old cherry papini reported
missing at about six o'clock last night
the report of a missing wife and mother
of two on november 2nd 2016 who
disappeared while out on a jog shocked
the tight-knit community of redding
california neighbors volunteered for
grit searches the networks landed to
cover the case just bring her home
bring her home safe and law enforcement
made finding sherry papini a top
priority says shasta county sheriff
michael johnson there was an extreme
amount of pressure put on law
enforcement the nation was watching and
locals were on edge
we used to walk meet my husband and i
said i'm not going to go walk by myself
no more private investigator bill garcia
was so concerned about the mom he
volunteered his services to her family
well i think it brought fear especially
to other women that it could happen to
them an anonymous donor offered a
six-figure reward to find papini who
reemerged at dawn 22 days later chained
bruised branded with a big story
sherry described her assailants as two
hispanic female adults
according to the fbi she accused the
women of brutally torturing her the hunt
was on and new fears settled in reading
where latinos were less than 10 percent
of the population a lot of people would
tell me you know and they had to be
hispanic and they have to be i said well
that doesn't give him a good name either
but so there was shame in the community
i guess she uh specifically picked out a
gender and a race to to name as the
suspect so any hispanic woman at that
time i'm sure is getting eyebrow raised
and looking in there wondering
whether she could be connected or one of
the suspects so people were being
questioned and stopped and asked
questions by law enforcement yes they
were afraid to go out and together in
one car or a van to women it could be
suspicious yeah to be suspicious or to
be stereotyped or to be insulted
gutierrez is a radio host and an
advocate for hispanic women she says for
many latinos in the area the more they
heard the less they bought papini's
story when they did the sketches like
she had a bandana like come on we don't
walk around like that we know the people
in our community through dna cell
tracking interviews from papini's former
boyfriend and other evidence the fbi
said its investigation indicated it was
all an expensive hoax by papini costing
taxpayers more than 230 thousand dollars
and to find out that it's all
for naught was was very frustrating in a
statement through her lawyer papini said
i'm deeply ashamed of myself for my
behavior and so sorry for the pain i've
cost my family my friends all the good
people who needlessly suffered because
of my story and those who worked so hard
to try to help me
meanwhile other missing women just
vanish from their homes and the
headlines like ilaria marmolejo a latina
and also a mother who disappeared two
months before papini from a neighboring
county these ladies deserve the same
respect and attention
like anybody else other cases are being
set aside and other real victims are not
getting served and other real suspects
are not being pursued because we're
chasing a ghost that doesn't even exist
for cbs mornings lilia luciano from
redding california
oh boy yeah this story is so maddening
because at the time a lot of us felt
that story was very fishy and it seemed
to keep changing but the way that she
just sort of blamed the hispanic
community at that particular time right
caused a lot very upsetting a lot of
people a lot of pain and pulled police
resources to her case which wasn't a
real case and took it away from all
these others right and when people who
were legitimately missing yeah they're
those time isn't given to that
particular case it'll be interesting to
see how she's sentenced it seems like
jail time could be in order here